[Music]
now the snp continues to ride high in
the polls despite having increasingly
divided internal factions
a vaccine roll out that lag somewhat
behind its english counterpart
generally uninspiring responds to the
pandemic
no worse but not that much better than
the london response
crucial hollywood elections hollywood
elections in may
could provide the smp with the mandate
they need for a second referendum
and the unionists are only just
realizing the scale of the task at hand
douglas ross
is leader of the scottish conservatives
he's fighting to stop nicola sturgeon
from getting the majority uh she wants
uh
he joins me now uh douglas ross welcome
to spectator tv
delighted to join you uh you've been
leading uh
the scottish stories now for six months
um
when you took over the tories were
polling on the constituency vote at 20
percent
uh they are now pulling at 20
you've made no impact well there was one
poll this morning that actually had us
up at 23
on the constituency 21 on the list but
i'm looking at where we were
at this stage five years ago so in 2016
in the run-up to the hollywood elections
we were pulling it at 15 and we went
into that election and stopped the snp
who were on roughly
similar figures as they are now and we
deny them that majority so
it shows it can be done but the only
party with the strength right across
scotland to do it
is the scottish conservatives but well
you say that but looking at your own
uh ratings the favorability rating for
douglas ross is 16 uh the favor
favorability rating for nicolas sturgeon
is 59 uh i mean there's quite a gap
again no real impact well
it's really difficult at the moment when
nicola sturgeon is on the bbc
every day doing a daily briefing rather
than addressing parliament as i think
people would expect the first minister
to make her statements to parliament and
i think there's ongoing discussions with
the bbc
how they have allowed the first minister
to politicize
in many cases these daily briefings and
giving her you know
a very strong platform which other
opposition parties
don't receive but i'm so
puzzled as to why you've not really made
any cut through i mean the
the snp thinks it's had a good pandemic
but the figures suggest
it hasn't really handled it that
differently from the
tories in england the vaccine rollout
has definitely been slower than england
there have been years of dismal results
under the snp now on
education and in health there are many
inquiries going on into the scottish
government and
the first minister there's a civil war
now raging in the snp
for everything from independent strategy
to gender identity i mean if you can't
cut through amid all that when are you
ever going to cut through
well there's a lot in that question so
let's just look at various different
points first of all on this
perception that nicola sturgeon has
handled this pandemic
any differently or better than the rest
of the uk i think you're right to call
out because we have had
problems and failures in scotland the
same as across the uk
and the figures don't suggest it's been
any better handled by nicolas surgeon
indeed we had the shocking case last
year where people that had tested
positive in hospital
were then released into care homes and
that was as a result
of smp scottish government advice
and guidance and indeed when are you
breaking
why aren't you if that's true why aren't
you breaking through
well here's the the nub of it andrew is
when there is a vote in parliament when
all the opposition parties say actually
we need an inquiry into this as a result
of these snp
failures they fail to do that they fail
to respect parliament and indeed we've
seen that
multiple times that we can have a vote
in parliament we can hold the smpg
account
and they simply ignore it and that is
unacceptable and we do have this
situation
where there are a litany of failures in
education
in health in rebuilding our economy
there has been a a sluggish
approach to business and the economy
here in scotland long before
kovid and we've just got to keep hitting
home these messages
but why then are you stuck at uh 20
in the polls or in the uh regional poll
uh you were around 16
in the comrades poll i mean if the snp
is as bad as you
say it is in governing scotland uh
certainly got a civil war going on at
the moment
it doesn't seem that people are paying
much attention to you
well there is obviously a problem with
getting cut through for politics at the
moment people are worried about their
job
they're worried about their relatives or
themselves getting cold but they're
worried about getting a vaccine and it
was right that the
scottish conservatives led the charge
against the asmp to get daily figures so
we knew how many people were being
vaccinated
and that's why we knew early on in this
process that scotland was lagging behind
the rest of the uk
now i'm pleased they up the ante and
they've up their efforts but we are
still
uh you know experiencing problems with
the vaccine rule i keep in scotland but
to go back to your question
you're right to raise it you know it's
difficult to cut through at the moment
when people are focused
on this pandemic
boris johnson described evolution as
quote a disaster
you rejected that description but there
hasn't been an opinion poll in scotland
now for almost a year
uh showing a majority in favor of the
union
uh and that the one last march uh
was only 51.49 i mean pretty much
statistically nip and tuck i mean if you
are a unionist in what way has
devolution not been a disaster
well i'm absolutely a unionist and the
prime minister clarified his remarks
remember
this is a prime minister who got that
top job because of devolution his time
is made of london
it ensured he was you know in a position
to then stand again for parliament to
become foreign secretary
and ultimately to be prime minister of
the united kingdom so he understands and
it fully respects how devolution works
but like me he's frustrated
that after 14 years of devolution in the
hands of the snp in scotland
we're seeing so many of our public
services suffering
and yet again you have no chance of
winning this election
well we're a long way out we've got to
look at the opinion polls as i say look
at how we are comparing now
compared to where we were five years ago
in this stage if you've been
interviewing ruth davidson you'd have
been saying the exact same thing you
can't stop an s p majority
and we did we won we're talking about a
an administration in edinburgh that's
been in power for what
14 years and is odds on favorite to be
re-elected
again perhaps with an overall majority
well we've got to see how the campaign
goes as i see andrew you know if you've
been sat here five years ago you'd have
been saying to ruth davidson
there was no chance that the scottish
conservatives could have stopped the snp
having that majority
and they did many people forget this but
nicolas surgeon went into that election
in 2016
with the majority and came out of it
having lost the majority
because the scottish conservatives more
than doubled their number of msps
if nicola sturgeon either gets an
overall majority or is still clearly
that the dominant uh power in hollywood
and forms another government
uh and proceeds by to to hold a
referendum
without the agreement of westminster
it's within the
jargon it's without a section 30
order um what should the
british government do well i know the
scottish conservatives will take no part
in a wildcat illegal referendum i want
to focus on scotland's recovery
after covert rather than another
referendum that's where every
political party should be aiming their
strengths their abilities and
their uh you know the mighty government
to make sure scotland gets back up and
running
after covet but absolutely i'm not going
to take part in any wildcat a legal
referendum and it just shows where the
smp have got to
they just want a referendum over
anything else and they are not willing
to
you know focus on what needs to be done
in scotland over the next five years
they want to rip us apart from the rest
of the united kingdom
and even if that means holding an
illegal referendum
so just to be clear under your
leadership the scottish tories would not
participate in in a referendum that was
not uh sanctioned by
the section 30 and that you would
encourage your voters or supporters
to stay at home yes absolutely
boycott it and show it for the reckless
referendum it is it's one that takes
away attention
and time from the real serious problems
we have here in scotland right now
for our education system the fact that
the snp are building hospitals that
can't take any patients
the fact that our economy is struggling
the fact that our justice system
seems to support the criminals more than
the victims these are where our focus
has to be and recovery
but rather than a referendum which if it
doesn't have that section 30 order then
it is not the gold standard referendum
that nicola sturgeon herself
said the 2014 referendum was but if
nicola sturgeon wins an
overall majority and fights the election
on a clear request for a mandate
to give her a mandate for a second
referendum and she gets an overall
majority as a right
as a result by what right do you have to
refuse of that second referendum
the fact that we were told just over six
years ago
that the 2014 referendum was a you know
a once in a generation vote that had
been
accepted by both sides as the gold
standard that's how you agree
for the uk government to get the section
30 order to greet the date the question
all of this yet now nicholas sturgeon
wants to rip that up
and appease her nationalist supporters
and say she would have a wildcat illegal
referendum enemy
what does that say to people up and down
scotland right now who are worried about
their job
worried about their their school for
their their son or daughter worried
about their health service
it for their uh you know family who
can't get into these hospitals at the
smp build that can't take any patients
it just shows that nicholas surgeon's
priority
is to the snp not the scottish people
but in the 2014 referendum the unionist
side your site
told scottish voters that the one sure
way to secure
scotland's continued uh participation in
the european union
was to vote to remain in the united
kingdom
how did that work out and then the
united kingdom had a democratic vote one
that was agreed by parliament supported
by politicians to ask the public if they
wanted to leave
or remain in the european union that is
how you deal with these
referendums you go through a process
which is clear
in law but you never mentioned that in
2014 and tony
in 2014 when the snp campaigned on
leaving the uk
but joining the eu as an independent
member
your side said there's no guarantee the
eu will accept you the only sure way you
can remain in the eu
is to stay in the uk and that turned out
to be
fundamentally wrong uh statement to the
scottish voters
well the scottish voters also knew there
was an opportunity if the conservatives
won a majority
in the election the following year that
it could be a manifesto commitment to
have
an in-out referendum on our place in
europe but then
let's also look at what the snp told the
people of scotland if you vote for
independence
will pay for everything with oil at over
a hundred dollars a barrel well oil
hasn't been over a hundred dollars a
barrel
at any point since that 2014 referendum
and that was certainly a misleading
statement from the snp
just one of many when we uh got on to
this
part of our interview but my original
question to you was
um what do you think or how would you
advise the government in london
to prevent or respond to
uh a wildcat referendum
what's the answer well i assume the
government in london would look at what
the
scottish conservatives are doing and
under my leadership i'm saying boycotted
don't get into this fight with the snp
over a wildcat referendum that distracts
from the uk government
scottish conservatives and what i think
every political party in scotland and
across the uk should be focused on
over this next five-year parliament
which is recovery rather than
referendums
if it's a wildcat or or some would call
it i think probably
you don't source would call it an
illegal referendum
should police scotland local authorities
returning officers
should they participate in the
administration of such a referendum
well there's two other people to mention
before it even gets here andrew what
about the lord advocate who is appointed
by the government so if nicolas sturgeon
is still at the first minister and
taking this through her political
appointment as the
lord advocate in a neutral way but he is
still appointed by the first minister
must give advice to the first minister
and say this is out with the remit and
the authority of the scottish parliament
and then the presiding officer of the
scottish parliament before
any vote is held on an illegal wildcat
referendum should be saying this is out
with the remit of the scottish
parliament how about nicolas surging you
deal with
education with health with policing
they're all within your remit focus on
them
rather than this wildcat illegal
referendum
so if scottish ministers government
ministers proceed with what
your view would be an illegal wildcat
your words referendum
should they face criminal charges well
they they have to be answerable for
their actions
why are they taking forward these plans
illegal
wildcat referendum plans in the middle
of a pandemic
when not only we are still trying to get
on top of the health emergency
we will have an economic emergency to to
fight
in the next few months and years ahead
so just for clarification uh whatever
the outcome of the holy
elections in may scottish tories will
oppose a second
independent referendum under any
circumstances during the next session of
the parliament
absolutely i don't want another divisive
referendum and people know
that across scotland the scottish
conservatives are the strongest party
to stand up for their interests for
scotland to remain an important part of
the united kingdom
to benefit from being part of that
family of four nations and to give so
much
to our four nations of the united
kingdom the
traditional response to the snp's demand
for independence or a referendum
has been to grant more powers to the
holyrood
parliament are you in favor of that i
just love to see the holyrood parliament
using the powers that's currently caught
you know they
jumped up and down and called for more
powers over social security and then the
snp found
they didn't have the capacity to deal
with that and they transferred them back
to westminster
and the uk government to handle for a
number of years so let's see
the scottish government actually using
the powers it's got right now
so just to be clear you would oppose
any more powers for the scottish
parliament for the moment
right now i want to see the scottish
parliament using the powers it's got
are you worried i mean the problems the
labour party has had
in scotland in recent years has allowed
the scottish stories to become the
second party
and in some ways the the unionist vote
has called
coalesced around the scottish uh tories
but there could be signs with the new
leader that the labour party
will be getting his act together maybe
not in time for the holy
elections or maybe it will be in in time
uh
are you worried that they could supplant
you as the main opposition to the snp
well i don't think they are in
opposition to the snp and that's the
problem under their former leader
richard leonard i offered to work with
him to say look if we can work together
after the next election to get rid of
this tired and feeling
smp government will you do it and he
said no so i then made the offer to
monica lenin and anna salwarp
we're standing for labour leader and
they turn that down as well so they
don't want to work with other parties
who support scotland's place in the
union
who will stand up for scotland to get
rid of the snp
and in fact we see in councils across
scotland they're actually perfectly
happy
to work with the snp so i think it's
clear to people that the labour party
are still stuck in this middle ground
and they're more likely to side with the
nationalists and keep them in power
than work with a pro-union party to get
rid of the snp
but the may elections for hollywood will
be the first real test of your
leadership
uh if you end up in third place
if labor does become second because
we're all assuming the snp will be first
if you're in third place that will
be a serious blow to your leadership
well i'm not putting a limit on
my ambitions for the scottish
conservatives in this election and i'm
up for this fight i'm really excited
about the positive policies
we're going to bring forward to take to
people across the country and show the
failures of this snp government
and indeed the failures of parties like
labour who are not willing to stand up
and be counted here
but if you beca if you came third behind
the snp
and that would be a problem for you
i'm not going to predict where i'm going
to come andrew but i'm sure i'll be
quite happy to come on again
and discuss the results on spectator tv
at once the people of scotland have cast
their votes and we know the outcome
oh douglas ross we'll hold you to that
thank you for the promise
and thank you for joining us on
spectator v on
tv on the week in 60 minutes the leader
of the scottish
conservatives douglas ross
[Music]
you